[Music]
well good afternoon dear friends i'm
glad that all of you decided to join us
this afternoon
this is a live program
that airs every tuesday at 4 30 in the
afternoon pacific standard time
and i have with me here c.a murray
associate speaker for secrets unsealed
good to see you ca good to be here as
always and you always look sharp
very kind of you right back at you well
thank you very much indeed um i just
want to give you the address if you want
to send us your questions it'll be on
the screen
tv at some tv dot org once again tv at
some tv
dot org you can send us your questions
bible questions we'll do everything
possible to answer those questions
we have several very interesting ones
this afternoon ca
and i think that before we do get into
taking a look at what the bible says we
need to do what we always do and that is
ask the lord's guidance as we open his
words amen would you please play i'm
glad to father god we praise you and
thank you for the privilege of studying
your word
you we are thankful that you have left
for us a record of your deeds your
doings your will your way your purpose
for mankind and we can open the word of
god ask for the spirit of god with the
understanding that spiritual things are
spiritually discerned so give us now the
mind of christ spiritual discernment
that we may rightly explain the word of
truth and that those who sit and consume
what we have to offer
will be given a clearer vision of the
king and the soon coming kingdom that
they may understand that christ is
coming soon and they must be ready for
that grand and glorious day
bless us just now we thank you for your
promise to hear and answer the prayer of
faith in jesus name amen
amen well ca what do we have today all
righty the first question
at the top of this list and i must say
pastor we are getting an impressive list
of questions i was
peeking on your desk the other day and i
saw this small
small mountain growing and growing and
growing which we like we are not
complaining this is not complaining we
like to have these questions the first
one deals with um
i want to ask a question this is coming
from worry
is god condoning or approving of wine or
alcohol
and strong drinks in deuteronomy 14 26
please explain this
verse to me if you will
this is deuteronomy okay maybe it would
be a good idea to read the verse first
indeed it's a deuteronomy chapter 14
and verse 26
14 26.
god is
actually the subtitle is tithing
principles
and it says
and you shall spend that money
for whatever your heart desires
that's other than the tithe money of
course
whatever your heart desires for oxen or
sheep
for wine or similar drink
for whatever your heart desires
you shall eat there before the lord your
god and you shall rejoice
you
and your household
so i think the gist of the question is
the expression for wine or similar drink
so
what can we say about the bible's
council when it comes to the issue of
alcoholic beverages
when you look at the totality of
scripture
that's everything that is said about
wine
you are left with the impression
that wine is not something that god
would have us
be involved in wine as a marker strong
drink is raging
and whose order is deceived by thereby
it's not wise that's one text that comes
to mind in other words who else who has
redness of i
who hath wounds without cause you know
they that stay long at the wind so the
the overall
tenor of the bible
says
to christians it is something to be
avoided
not to be imbibed as they say today
responsibly but not to be touched at all
and that goes with all alcoholic
beverages because of the effect they
have on the body and the mind so this
must be
uh
either an anomaly or there's something
else going on here
and we've got to look at it in that term
in those terms i looked up both of the
words for
the wine and strong drink they both
refer to fermented alcohol
fermented wine so what the bible is
saying
here is is a little bit something
different
i looked this up actually in the sj
bible commentary because i was running
into a lot of things that i didn't uh
quite know what was saying and it the
estee bible commentary says
interestingly enough
that this is one of those things that uh
the people of god were
were uh
they weren't fully the people of god yet
and that god allowed this uh
like he allowed some other things like
divorce and nothing because of the
hardness of their heart
there was a time when god drew a line to
this um i looked up a couple texts acts
of
acts 17 30.
there comes a time when god puts the
truth before you and you're called from
that point on to
walk in the truth but before
those times
when the truth is not made clear then
god allows for certain things that he
later clears up once you are
aware of what god's commandments are so
god winked at the times of their
ignorance in other words precisely
[Laughter]
just to use an analogy
the pioneers of the seventh adventist
church
were notorious
swine eaters oh yes they ate pig until
the great
vision that ellen white received on
health reform in 1863 oh yes and then
god showed them clearly that they should
not be eating pork and other things that
were detrimental to their health
and so they quit doing it yes so uh you
know
truth is progressive
and god gives it only as people are able
to receive it yes
however there are other texts in the
bible that make it very clear
that we should not partake of a strong
drink
maybe we can look at some of those
proverbs 20 verse 1. obviously
proverbs 20 verse 1 cannot contradict
deuteronomy 14 verse 26 because the
bible doesn't contradict itself correct
so i think you have to take a look at
what you were mentioning that you know
this is as israel is going to enter the
promised land
and uh and god is telling them
you know
not the final truth which he will be
revealed revealing later on but he's
leading them step by step yes so um
proverbs 20 verse one you want to read
that wine is a mocker strong drink is a
brawler
old king james says is raging and
whosoever and whosoever is led astray
by it is not wise
okay so
uh it says wine is a mocker
let's read also chapter 31.
proverbs 31
and verses 4 through 7.
speaking about kings in this case
it is not for kings o lemuel
it is not for kings to drink wine
nor for princes intoxicating drink
lest they drink and forget the law
and pervert the justice of all the
afflicted
interesting so
does
getting drunk
affect your perception of the law indeed
it does
you know and it says that it perverts
the justice of all the afflicted because
in the old testament people would go uh
to the king for justice yes
and if the king was under the influence
he would not be able to see straight and
he would not be able to meet all justice
very very true so it says
then it says give strong drink to him
who is perishing
and whine to those who are bitter of
heart
let him drink and forget his poverty and
remember his misery no more so alcohol
is not for those who are walking in the
ways of the lord no no you know ellen
white says even on the cross when christ
was offered pulse which is not not
alcohol per se but it did have
pain numbing effects he refused to take
it because he wanted all of his senses
he wanted all of his wits about him he
wanted to be very clear about what he
was saying what he was doing what he was
going through so he wouldn't even take
basically an anesthetic or a narcotic
right because of its dulling effects so
we don't want to be
under the influence of something that
that
you know moves our thinking in the wrong
direction yeah yeah and then you have
the story of native and abaihil oh yeah
which is really powerful
uh you know we can go to
leviticus chapter 10 because there are
some important lessons that we need to
learn from this
uh leviticus chapter 10
uh of course probably most of those who
are watching the program uh know
uh the story uh the two sons of aaron oh
yeah they went into the sanctuary and
they took common fire or strange fire
the bible says
which was fire
not from the altar where god had rained
the fire it wasn't holy fire it was
common fire yes
and so they went in before the lord with
common fire
and the bible says that the glory of the
lord came out and consumed them
now why were they not able to
distinguish between the holy and the
common
chapter 10
and verses 8 through 10 tell us why they
were not able to discriminate between uh
truth and error between holy and common
you want to read verses
8-10 then the lord spoke
to aaron saying do not drink wine or
intoxicating drink
you
nor your sons with you
when you go into the tabernacle of
meeting lest you die
it shall be a statute forever throughout
your generations that you may
distinguish between holy and unholy
between clean
and
between unclean rather and clean
okay and verse 11
and that
you may teach the children of israel all
the statutes which the lord has spoken
to them by the hand of moses so two
things here first of all
when you drink intoxicating drinks it
says you're not able to do what this
distinguish between the holy and the
common
and secondly you are not able to teach
the children of israel or the church for
that matter all the statutes which the
lord god has spoken to them by the hand
of moses yes yes so it's a very serious
thing now
it seems like a small thing because
there was fire burning that was supposed
to be kept burning at all times wasn't
supposed to go out if you
rub two sticks together or use a
magnifying glass or strike a match of
you that's common fire that's not what
the lord kindle that's just a fire you
start right and and it doesn't seem like
a big deal and of course if you're drunk
or intoxicated it's going to seem less
like a big deal so you're going to take
some common fire but evidently it was a
big deal to god it had something to say
about god's relationship to his people
that's something to say about what was
happening in the temple and it was not
allowed they got they drank wine they
lost their discernment and uh they made
that mistake yeah i guess god is
persnickety huh yeah
god you know he when he says something
he's serious about it
i have not heard that word in many years
person
but but it is a good word because god is
particular
about what he wants from his people
because
the commands as you well know pastor
being a student of the word uh that god
gives us are our they're in
instructional but they're also for our
own good i mean god is teaching us
discipline he's teaching us reverence
he's teaching us the principles of
worship and they are for their best and
if god says he wants it a foot long he
doesn't want it two feet long or 18
inches he wants it a foot right yeah
yeah and people who are drunk kind of
say some foolish things yes and do you
think they do so so you know god wants
us to be all there
he wants us to have a clear mind
so that we can discern his will
and we can think straight
um you know there's another story that
you know before we go to the next
question another story which is very
interesting it's the story about chaser
in chapter 5 of daniel
you know um
the story of nadab and abahu
teaches us the lesson that you should
not take what is common
and present it to god is holy
but the story in daniel 5 teaches us
that we should not take what is holy and
treat it as as if it were common very
true so the two sides of the coin in
other words so let's notice daniel
chapter five
and maybe read verses uh one the three
one two three all right daniel five
one two three
it's always that last page i'll get to
you know
yeah that's a newer bible if i remember
correctly indeed it is okay daniel 5 1
the king made a great feast for a
thousand of his lords and drank wine in
the presence of the thousand
while he tasted the wine belshazzar gave
the command to bring
the gold and silver vessels which his
father nebuchadnezzar had taken from the
temple which had been in jerusalem that
the king and his lords his wives and his
concubines might drink from them in
verse 3 then they brought the gold
vessels
that had been taken from the temple of
the house of god which had been in
jerusalem and the king and his lords his
wives and his concubines drank from them
so the case here is that he's taking
holy vessels
and he's treating them as if they were
common
whereas in the story of nadab and abayu
they're taking common fire and they're
presented to god as if it was holy yes
and notice the very next verse verse 4
when you can when you don't distinguish
between the holy and common you fall
into idolatry yes verse 4
they drank wine and praise the gods of
gold and silver bronze and iron wood and
stone
so very serious yes yes and the bible is
careful to give you a sequence here they
were drinking already so they are
already inebriated then he says let's go
and take these these uh vessels and and
drink from them so they they had been
drinking yeah so now they they they take
god's holy vessels and uh
throw them into their party basically
yeah actually it says while he tasted
the wine
bill chaser gave the command so he was
already uh he was already drinking
he was drinking
so i think
i think the bible is clear
you know that
we really should not drink alcohol yes
there's always you know it's addicting
and uh
some people simply cannot handle they'll
say you know just drink a little bit but
then a little bit leads to more and more
to more until finally people are
alcoholics yeah yeah and everybody says
i never thought and of course no one
ever does think it would be you but
when you play with fire can a man take
fire into his bone and not be burned uh
sooner or later it's going to get you
yeah yeah the bible says we're supposed
to take care of our body indeed because
uh you know the bible says whether you
eat or drink or whatever you do
do all to the glory amen of god that's
first corinthians 10 31
and
first contains
uh is a very strong strong
set of
lessons for god's people okay very good
so now we have another question this is
a very interesting one
uh and uh it's somewhat of a long it's
prefaced with uh some comments
so i'm gonna go through it quickly i
have a younger brother
who struggles with drug addiction for
over 15 years
in and out of prison homeless etc
we invited him to stay a night in a tent
in our backyard
the following morning i dropped him off
at a homeless shelter
i didn't offer him to wash or eat
as we were driving to the shelter he
wanted to go to my mom's house which has
always been his escape
for many years we have invited him to
church
bible studies and social gatherings at
he attended but has not gained the
victory yet
he has four children
and lives with the mom of his children
as you can imagine there is more to
samuel's life my husband
son and i have helped samuel in every
way possible
i have not lost hope
for i know our jesus lives and makes
intercession for us
but i have definitely changed my ways
about how to help him
for instance
this last time he spent the night at
home
in the morning i didn't offer him any
aid because when he gets fed and clean
he refuses to stay in rehab or in a
shelter and he goes back to the streets
and returns sadly intoxicated now here
comes the question based on this
scenario
my question is
did i fail to keep matthew 25
which says i was hungry you gave me to
eat i was thirsty you gave me the drink
i was
homeless you gave me shelter basically
so
did i fail to keep matthew 25 where
jesus talks about feeding the hungry
thirsty etc and if i have how can i make
amends
so that is the question
so what can we say about that
you know pastor
i had
i can't say have had a brother
who was
uh involved in drugs also
he died at age 36
back in
the early 90s
and we
tr
dealing with drug addicted people you
talk about alcohol
uh takes away your will
drugs can completely control your life
control your decisions
um
and my parents had a very hard time
dealing with with uh gordon
um
but
without being an enabler
you got to try to help them as best you
can
um and it's
it's kind of a dicey thing you know that
i'm looking at james chapter 2 verse 16.
to tell somebody be healed be warm be
clothed and not assist in that
um
you're you're called to assist in that
sometimes you got to do tough love um
i have had
uh
stay in my home uh
someone who had just come out of prison
um i don't know now that i'm a little
older maybe a little wiser if i would do
that again
um i might take them to a hotel and uh
and that kind of thing but you've got to
extend yourself as best you can which
will that is still safe for you
and extend yourself
as best you can to help those
particularly of your own family
who need your help it's a it's a touchy
area but you want to be able to feel
that you've done your best for them
given the circumstances that you're
handed
so basically
the council is
that um the person who asked is asking
the question
is that she should actually
uh help him
as matthew chapter 25 uh
tells us we're supposed to do
i you know again it's a how is it ever
too late i don't think it's ever too
late to show the love of christ
um
but
we ought not let go unimproved
those opportunities that the lord gives
to us to to lend a helping hand
particularly to our to our own family
and friends
what would you recommend
for them to do
in terms of
really helping to resolve the problem
that he has because it's one thing you
know to provide him a place to take a
bath and a place you know food to eat
but that doesn't solve the
the greater problem which is the problem
of uh
drug addiction
and so what can be done
to help him with this real issue his
real problem
the thing about being a drugged a drug
addicted person
is that
the motivation for
correcting that problem
has to ultimately come from within
you cannot superimpose
correction on a person who does not want
to be corrected
having dealt with
many drug addicted
persons
more than my share
in family out of family i know that um
you cannot provide will for them that
will has to come from within um
you take them
sometimes they stay many times they do
not
but make sure that you you've done your
best before you wash your hands before
you uh
sort of clear yourself make sure that
you you you've made the sacrifices
necessary so so that you can say
i've done all i can do
for this individual so in other words
sometimes you have to wait till they hit
rock bottom
and they see that
that they're going nowhere and the holy
spirit speaks to their hearts
and then from within they decide that
it's time to really straighten out the
life through the power of god
yeah
sometimes and sometimes you've got to
let them
hit rock bottom and take away the
mattress
by that let them feel the pain of
hitting rock bottom
you know moms and and my mother was was
like this my dad was one way my mom was
the other um
she had always put like a little safety
net under there you know so he didn't
hit hard well sometimes you got to let
them hit hard so they feel the pain of
that bump and that can help return
rather than putting a blanket down so
the landing is always soft and they've
already got a home to come to and always
gotta you know leave the light on in the
window kind of thing that does not
always help uh-huh yeah
okay well it's a complicated situation
it is it is not and each case is
different than the other
you know they're not all identical
they're not all the same
uh so
i hope that the council has been useful
we don't always have all the answers god
has the answers yes the holy spirit
working within one thing
that definitely can be done
is to continue continue praying oh yes
for samuel
you know because uh you know and you
know it's a risky business to say lord
do whatever is necessary
yes
and mean it
yeah if you really mean it
so that samuel can be saved in your
kingdom yes yes you know even if it
means negative things happening in this
life yes you know do whatever it takes
to reach him
very very true
the best thing you can do for your best
friend
is also the best thing you can do for
your worst enemy and that's pray for
them uh in either case prayer is the
best thing you can do so you want to
bathe every decision with prayer and
then go ahead and make the tough
decisions and leave it to the lord amen
okay we have another question i don't
know whether we're going to be able to
answer this one in the time frame we
have
but we'll give it a whirl
we have a couple that is preparing for
baptism
in their past they did a lot of dancing
winning contests
i assume that it's winning the contest
and dancing
they asked a question recently about
dancing
if it was okay for adventists to dance
what is wrong with it
as long as you don't do it on sabbath
so
what can we say about dancing
i uh
well confession is good for so hard and
reputation so maybe we just leave that
alone um
i would i would move away from that and
here's why
um the kinds of places that you have to
go the kinds of things you have to
subject yourself to
i don't know if the spirit of god can
join you in that or bless that activity
and
you know in in adventism
so many times we want to get as close to
the edge as we can and not go off
really rather than try to work at the
edge of this table you want to move
towards the middle to the safe side you
don't want to be as close to the edge as
you can
so move away sometimes we have to let go
of some things that are cherished
really cherished
uh by us uh we've got to let them go
dance competition first of all it takes
time
uh to get that good because they're
talking about professional dancing now
this is not just you know clubbing on
the weekends this is professional stuff
well you got to put in time that's time
that can be used doing other things uh
for the lord uh you got costumes you got
clothing uh i
a stepdaughter who was a ballet teacher
and uh man she put in a lot of time
choreographing sewing costumes doing
things
and now she looks back boy that's a lot
of time i don't have i can't get back so
sometimes you got to say no to some
things that are maybe in and of
themselves not totally wrong but they
just they're not convenient for the
christian you know there are other
things we can do for the cause of christ
uh i look at this vast amount of
material that you produce what if you
spent that time dancing
that wouldn't happen
very true very true but but my point is
you could never
put out the materials you know if you
split your time doing other kinds of
things you've got to be kind of focused
on and of course you have a special
calling on your life but so does every
christian they are calling on all
christians to lift up the name of jesus
um and the time that you spend dancing
is time you're spinning away from doing
what your main job is and that's being
about your father's business
very very good point
uh so
you know the bible does speak about
david dancing
maybe we can address that in a different
program because time is just about up
you know some people take stories in the
bible and they justify what they want to
do by the stories
nowhere does it say that god approved of
david dancing
you know the bible just records it but
the bible records things
without pronouncing a moral judgment and
by the consequences you can kindly see
kind of see what god's counsel is
because david dancing in the streets
led saul to be jealous of him
so anyway well time is just about up so
uh
why don't you just go ahead and finish
up
again we you see the kind of fun we have
going into the word i i love setting the
word with with pastor bohr and the time
goes so very very fast keep sending in
your questions it it it thrills us to
answer your questions and to learn from
the word of god again tv at some tv dot
o r g you send in the questions we will
answer them by the grace of god and we
will see you next time
[Music]